Hey, what's up everybody?
How are we doing? How was your weekend?
Let me see if I can from a chat. Where's my chat?
Uh, good, good, good, good, good. How's everybody doing?
Good. Are we doing good? Hey Jay, how you doing?
Uh, who else is on the call? Type the chat.
Lemme know if you're on the call. I know people are
still coming in.
If you can let the groups know, gee,
that we are live on the call.
Let me do that too. I didn't think of that.
I'll tell everybody in the, uh, local newsletter room.
Hold on a second. Where is that room?
Where is that room? It's called Marketers Community.
Okay, hold on a second.
Uh, we are live on the call.
Uh, gee, where do I send them
to get on this call? Is it local?
You can send them to 10 name.
Okay. Local newsletter
hustle.com/ 10:00 AM
Uh, alright, this is our third session on the Zoom
webinar So far I like it.
It's pretty good. Uh,
it's definitely keeping us on our toes.
The reason why is 'cause the replays
go out automatically or whatever.
And so if we don't get the uh, link in time,
that's a problem.
Um, but it's okay. So, yeah.
Uh, I did have my 50th, uh, birthday party.
That was pretty incredible, right?
We went and saw a show in Vegas and had dinner
and uh, then I had my first Japanese cheesecake
and wow, is that a good cake?
That's pretty incredible.
I don't know if you guys have ever had a,
a Japanese cheesecake, but man, that's good cake.
Um, okay, cool.
Let me put this in the link here
to local newsletter hustle.com/
10:00 AM Is that the right link?
Gee, let's see. Uh, I think that's the right link.
Alright, lemme put this in the messenger room too.
Um, and I'll tell you guys what we have going on.
Uh, let's see, where's that room? Oh, that's not in Zoom.
That is in Messenger. Okay. So is there a round table today?
There's no such thing as a round table anymore.
Round table's been retired, uh, coming up on a year.
Uh, we used to have the round table we retired at, uh,
when the newsletter thing got hot and heavy.
So look, here's the thing guys.
Um, we've been experimenting with some things, uh,
that I wanted to tell you about.
I haven't really been, uh, too excited about,
um, AI where it was.
And the reason why is
because I said, okay, that's not the time to, um,
start working with people.
Meaning that's not the time
to start doing workshops and everything.
Like we're known to do.
Like, we're the ones that created the whole
workshop model, right?
We did it back in 2017
before challenges came out
or anything, I, I said, you know, I wanna take my software
and I wanna show people how to use it,
put a countdown timer on the screen and have people do it
and celebrate their success.
And nothing like that had ever taken place before.
And I was using Facebook groups and I was using my wall,
and now pretty much everybody's copying me.
Like you might notice when people have like 150 comments,
it's because they have people on a Zoom call
and they're so,
everybody's like copying everything I've ever done.
So I'm ready to get back in the game.
But it wasn't gonna be with ai
'cause AI was evolving too fast.
Um, but I'm gonna tell you right now
that we did not necessarily jump aboard the, uh,
vibe coating bandwagon or anything else.
Um, but we have been experimenting with something
that I believe is, is a level higher than that.
Um, and we're gonna do a workshop here pretty soon,
but I wanna make sure that we have proven everything out.
So just to kind of give you a, um, a recap,
the reason why I mention this on this call is
because I think you can have an assistant
that's gonna write your newsletter for you
and, uh, write articles for you.
And the reason why is
because this assistant, this bot, would learn
so much about you and your business.
And what do I mean by that?
It knows your city, it knows your population.
It knows you put a newsletter out every single Tuesday.
It knows that you want to have at least four articles.
So it's al it's always looking for the, the latest news.
It it, it can be trained to go into Google News.
It can be trained to monitor your alerts.
It can be trained where if somebody replies
to your email about your newsletter, it can,
it can re it can handle that for you, right?
And so what we've set up is we have kind
of like a messenger communication where we can talk to, uh,
this agent, this bot and say, Hey, can you do me a favor?
This person message about this, can you shoot 'em a link?
Hey, um, you know, this person uh, wants to book this time
or whatever, but they're not available Tuesday.
Can you see what, what's the best time on my calendar?
Uh, my daughter, uh, we bought her, um, a,
a deal on Amazon for her birthday.
So we just tell the bot, Hey, do me a favor. Here's a link.
Go buy this thing. That's kind of where we're at.
And not only that, I know you guys have heard a lot about
the term vibe coding and everything.
And so that required you having like clog code or Xcode
or whatever and you would jump in there
and learn vibe coding.
No. And that's the reason why I didn't want you to do it
because see now the bots will just do all the
coding for you.
That's the level we're at.
That's where I have taken interest.
Now I'm like, okay, now things are starting to make sense.
Everything up to this point has been little piecemealing,
you know, things together kind
of the same way we build software, right?
We build it piece by piece.
And then once we have all these pieces and,
and once things are kind of flowing, then we're like, okay,
now we got an ecosystem.
Well, I believe that, uh, AI is now to
where we have an ecosystem where you can actually, uh,
talk to you.
You're, this is way different guys.
Everything up to this point has been you telling
AI what you want it to do.
Now AI's gonna tell you what to do.
In other words, hey Chad, uh, you got a domain
that's getting ready to expire?
Do you want me to renew it for you?
Oh, Pacino, please go do that for me. Thank you so much.
You're great. Hey, uh, Chad, don't forget,
we just ended this call
and the replay's gotta be up by 10:00 AM tomorrow morning.
Or, uh, people are gonna click and not be able to get that.
Great. Do me a favor.
Can you go set up that replay or whatever? Yeah.
How do you think about this? How,
what do you think about this headline?
Do you think this headline perfect. That's great. Boom.
There you go. Replays up.
Hey um, Chad, I just checked in with the teams or whatever.
They're having trouble building this
and they're stuck over here on this
API You got any thoughts on this?
'cause I'm thinking we can probably do this. Yeah, perfect.
Alright, awesome. Hey Chad,
we got this workshop coming up this weekend
for the local newsletter, hustle, whatever.
Here's the outline based off your old workshop,
but here's what I'm thinking we can add to this.
What do you think about that? Boom. Perfect. Right?
Uh, hey Chad, don't forget you got the freaking local
newsletter call in an hour.
Here's all the local, here's all the new
newsletters that we did for this week.
Do you guys understand this? So when you hear about stuff
like autonomous and agentic
and all that stuff, that gets complicated.
We're not gonna do complicated guys.
Leave complicated to the bone heads
that are just out there trying to sell you something.
What I'm gonna do is put together a very simple process
where you don't have to go and buy an expensive MacBook.
You don't have to have a big processing server,
you don't have to have a lot of expenses.
Now I'm gonna train you exactly.
I'm gonna tell you exactly how to train that bot.
I'm gonna tell you exactly what you need to do.
The memory banks you can set up like
there's so much stuff you can do.
We'll do it workshop stop.
But my main thing is I want it to be able
to handle our local newsletter.
Does that make sense to you guys?
How many of you're pretty excited to hear that?
How many of you're pretty excited to hear?
And like I said, my team has been, you know, a lot
of people would say, okay, but Chad, you know what?
You don't need a team anymore
'cause this thing can do everything for you.
I'm like, hell no, man. I love my team.
I don't wanna let go of my team.
Instead, what I want my team to do is I want my team working
with me to make sure that we are cutting edge
and cracking the code to all these things.
And then I have a big audience.
So we're gonna go back out there.
We're gonna do like we started in 2017.
We're gonna take back the damn workshop model.
'cause that was my model.
Everybody just ripped me off, right?
So, um, that's gonna be pretty exciting.
You guys are gonna see that. You're gonna see
AI creating the articles for you.
You're gonna see ai, uh, writing the newsletter for you're,
you're gonna see all that stuff, right?
And, uh, we're, we're experimenting with all this right now.
But here's the thing, man, I am very, very confident that
that damn thing is gonna log into Letterman.
It's gonna know how to use it
and it's gonna create everything for you.
It's gonna create those articles for you.
It's gonna come up with a headline,
it's gonna analyze the SEO, it's gonna do all those things.
We don't even have to everything.
We're understanding, we don't even have to build it in.
This isn't like we're gonna tap into the API.
No, no, this thing is like going to learn how
to log in a Letterman
and it knows it goes out every single Tuesday.
It knows it goes out by 7:00 AM It knows it needs, you know,
four articles from Summerland, two from Save the Doggy
and one from, uh, Vegas for like,
it just knows those things.
Does that make sense? It just knows those things.
So my thing is, guys, yeah, you're damn right, we are going
to train it on how to use Letterman on how
to use Mint Bird on how to use pop links on how to use GC
so that, you know, if you set up a page or whatever
and it's like, Hey, we're missing a tag here,
it knows you're missing a tag, Chad, like you're trying
to put people in their membership or whatever, right?
You said you wanted to the page to uh, you know,
give them access to Core Sprout and then do this.
But you, your tag doesn't put 'em in. It can learn.
It can be like your biggest employee for you.
Now, I think this is scary.
I think this is really, really scary.
And I don't think the world's ready for the infrastructure.
They don't have the infrastructure.
They, they, they're not ready for this.
But I'm gonna tell you right now, a lot of VAs, a lot
of just, my God, there's a lot
that's gonna be changing very, very fast.
And, uh, you know, we didn't think this was gonna be here
for another 10 or so years.
It's here, it's here right now, guys.
This thing is here right now. Okay?
So, uh, we, when I say we,
my team will crack the code to this
and we will make it work with all of our software.
And this is what's so brilliant about all this.
How many of you are now starting to connect the dots
and you, and you're going, Chad you made your software
so easy that a freaking bot could actually run the
software a a buy could.
If I said, Hey, do me a favor, go create a pop link for the,
for the workshop this weekend.
It could do it, it could do it, it might say,
Hey, what domain do you wanna use?
Ah, just use Chad nicely. Boom.
It could do it, it could absolutely do it.
If I said, Hey, you know, I'm trying to put together a guide
for a hundred.
We, we did this. I hired a VA
to help me put together the next guide
for all the subscription boxes, okay?
All the subscription boxes.
Now, I can simply say to Pacino, Hey,
that's why I named it Pacino.
Hey, do me a favor
and go find all of the food subscription boxes or whatever.
We're gonna put it into, uh, a PowerPoint.
Here's the domain, let's go ahead
and then let's create a page.
And, uh, let's, let's fire off this tag to deliver, uh,
this, this incredible cheat sheet.
Like, it it could do all these things, guys.
So up to this point, I haven't been interested in you
sitting down and trying to clean up interfaces
and APIs and everything else.
I I have not been interested in that.
And here's the reason why, because I'm seeing all
of these people, I'm sure you guys have seen this.
If you open up your Facebook,
people are copying what I've done, right?
I saw another guy this weekend.
Hey, show me your chat bot
that you built this weekend, right?
Show me this, show me that, like all of 'em are copying me
and there's like 150 comments.
And so I go in there and I saw 150 people created a, uh, uh,
freaking vibe code app.
Great. So the value of software just went
right down the tube.
Right? Now all these people
are creating all this software, right?
These stupid little apps,
and they don't know how to sell 'em.
They can't even give 'em away because it is so diluted.
Does that make sense? So when you have something incredible
like Letterman, when you have something incredible like
Mper, when you have something that everybody, regardless
of your level can plug in, can put a button on a page,
can bring in subscribers, can have a real tangible asset.
Guys, these little freaking apps that are being built,
there's no value.
There's no value.
You can't even give those things away on your wall.
The reason why it's gonna work for us is
because we're plugging 'em into GC makes sense?
We're plugging them into an ecosystem.
But if you don't have an ecosystem,
you're dead in the water.
What do you got? This simple little app,
nobody's gonna pay for it.
Why would somebody pay for it when you could take the same
exact app to say, can you build this for me?
It doesn't make sense anymore. So it's losing its value.
They're not gonna tell you that.
They're gonna tell you, oh, you can go out there
and build an app that you're gonna make $300,000 a year.
No, you're not. No you're not.
It doesn't happen that way, folks.
Not when somebody could build the app
and then take a screenshot of it
and then give it to Claude Code
and say, here, can you go rebuild this for me?
No, it's, it's gone. It's game over.
We're still years away from Full Stack.
It can't figure out the complexity like we have
with Member Bird and Letterman.
We're still, we're still pretty far away from that.
But here's the other thing, guys.
I've been telling you this for years.
I've been telling you this for a long time, okay?
And this is what I want you to take from me, okay?
Uh, when I built Member Hub, which became Everlast,
you know, how many people ripped me off?
How many of you know how many people this was
before the days of AI or anything else?
Matter of fact, I got somebody who went out
there and knocked off Letterman.
Can you believe that I got somebody
that knocked off Letterman?
Not only that, I got this bonehead out there named Drew
Griffin that is just throwing stones at me.
When you, when you treat your, your, uh, local newsletter,
like something besides a hustle, like, dude, you don't want
to throw stones at me.
I'm the originator.
I'm the one that paved the way
for this whole local newsletter thing.
You're better off playing with me,
not throwing stones at me.
But here's the thing, you can rip me off,
you can rip off my software, you can do all that stuff,
but you know what you don't know how to do?
You don't know how to build a community
and you don't know how to get people to finish line
and you don't know how to motivate people.
So yeah, people were ripping off ever
lesson back in the day.
I can remember a customers hitting me up saying, Chad,
this thing just launched on JV Zoo.
And they like, they copied ever lesson
verbatim, okay?
And guess what? I never heard from it ever again.
The launch bomb, they went on
to build something else, right?
It's the community guys.
So look, if you're gonna go build a,
a freaking vibe code app
or whatever, use it to create a community around it.
See, if I was gonna go build a Vibe code app,
I'd build the damn app.
And then I'd say, and you know what?
This weekend, uh, not only am I gonna give you the app,
I'm gonna show you how to do it.
And when it's all said and done,
here's what you're gonna have.
See, that's the difference, folks.
It's the combination of both.
Does it have to be a freaking app? No. No it doesn't.
Guys, I went out there in a single day
and created Hustle 2.0 who has gone
through Hustle 2.0.
And by the way, if you haven't, I'm gonna give it away
for free on this call today.
I'm gonna give it to you. You're gonna get the $297 software
plus local newsletter,
1.0 plus Hustle 2.0 plus the SMT Quickstart Guide.
If you didn't get that last week,
my birthday's finally coming to an end.
I've been giving it away my whole
entire birthday for the whole month.
Uh, well I've been giving away,
but I didn't give away hustle until last week.
Uh, and I think it's gonna really help you.
So type the chat here. Who picked up Hustle 2.0?
Matter of fact, let me share it on the screen here.
I want you guys to see this and I realize I made a mistake.
Don't worry about it guys. I'll fix it.
I'm the kind of guy that definitely does not do everything
perfectly, but I get stuff out fast.
Um, if you see screen number one here, all right,
so I'm actually logged in as a mastermind member.
So if you're a mastermind, boom.
But you can see over here an hour ago,
Steve posted, uh, not online.
50% confident. Excited, very excited.
A hundred percent ideas are flowing. Yeah.
Ron says, the sovereign vision,
a response to the ledger's growth.
I don't know what that means, Ron. Uh, yeah.
So you can see all these comments are coming in
over here, right?
I've been online since 1980s. Coaching, selling, mentoring.
Yep. Okay, good. So, uh, that's the activity.
But if I come over here to Hustle
2.0, here it is right here.
So if we open this up, good.
We've had 39 comments here, 26 goals, guys, this is
how we do things.
So if you've already gone through Hustle 1.0
and I screwed up your last badge, I'll fix that for you.
But if you've already gone through, uh, hustle 2.0,
type the chat on a scale of one out of 10,
how did I do, how did I do?
No, this is just not, this is not just for the Mastermind.
You don't even have to buy this.
I am giving this to you, Winston.
I am giving this to you for my birthday,
and I'm gonna tell you the reason why, okay?
I'm gonna tell you the absolute reason why
and I don't want anybody p****d off at me or anything else,
but this is my 50th birthday
and I wanted it
to be the most incredible month of your life.
And I'm gonna tell you the reason why, okay?
But first, let's look at Hustle 2.0.
All right, look at this. And we're
at a hundred people on the call.
That's amazing. So look up here,
I talk about what's new in Hustle 2.0,
you're gonna hear about ai,
you're gonna hear about the articles,
you're gonna hear about how we create newsletters.
You're gonna hear about the latest news, right?
You're gonna hear about all the latest things
that we did in the past year.
I gotta reshoot this video.
Connie's like, ah, that's too dark. We have to reshoot it.
I agree with her. So we'll reshoot the video.
We'll make it look like a million bucks, right?
But I did it fast. I did it all in one day.
So what do you want? Right? Uh, how about
how we create newsletters in 2.0?
Matter of fact, let's take a look at what some
of these people are saying here.
Uh, and uh, G
or pne, if you wanna drop the birthday link in there,
you guys can go to Chad nicely.com/birthday.
Let me make sure pne, do we have that tag set up
for the software too?
Yes. Perfect. Chad nicely.com/birthday.
Jump in there. Uh, let's see, a hundred percent committed.
I'm a hundred percent. I'm doing restart.
A hundred percent in the newsletter.
Has huge potential, tons of hidden value.
I'm a hundred percent committed to taking consistent action.
I'm in a hundred percent. Let's go ahead and load some more.
What do we got excited about all of the updates?
Yes, I'm a hundred percent committed.
My newsletter will got every single week.
A hundred percent, a hundred percent. All looks amazing.
Good. So you'll go through that first one, right?
Uh, but then let's come over here.
Let's look at like, uh, how we create newsletters in 2.0.
So this talk specifically, you can see
how there's a goal block on every single one
of our lessons, okay?
And if I come over here and if I look at the comments,
you can see, I see the value in creating articles,
adding them to my newsletter.
Can't wait to crush it. Anxious to get the ball rolling.
Yes, yes. It's really clear how valuable they are.
I could see how this easily dominates a local search.
This makes putting a newsletter together fast and painless.
Uh, let's see what else James says.
The fact that this advancement moves the needles
and powering without spinning a nickel on Apen.
Guys, look, here's the thing, man.
I already told you what's coming.
I already told you that your bot,
I'm gonna help you do this.
Your bot is gonna do all this stuff for you.
But let me give you the most valuable advice
that I can possibly give you when it comes to your,
your bot is gonna be an employee that all of you can afford.
It's gonna employ, it'll be an employee
that never calls in sick, never argues,
always has a solution
and learns everything about your business.
I'm gonna help you guys do this. I promise you,
I will help you do this.
I'm the very best one to help you do this.
But here's the thing. I've worked with many people.
I still have all my teams for the past 15 years.
I've, I've maintained my teams.
I've seen a lot of people come and go in this business.
They couldn't hang, they couldn't hang when COVID hit.
They couldn't hang when things got bad. I'm still here.
I've been here since 19, 19 98 going stronger
than ever, okay?
Running two teams now, two different companies.
But here's the thing. This is what I'm gonna tell you
before, before you can expect any employee to step in
and do anything, you need to understand it yourself
before you can expect any bot,
which is now gonna be your employee to step in.
You gotta understand it yourself. Does that make sense?
You guys gotta understand the value of the articles.
You gotta understand how we create the
newsletter from the articles.
How 70% of your newsletter should be articles
and everything else that we taught in one point.
Oh. You gotta understand all these things folks.
All of these things. And my plan is I appreciate the fact
somebody mentioned Mint Bird and GC and everything else.
And you know, we built our software
where it's super, super easy.
And guess what? The same exact way
that I'm gonna train my Pacino,
we're already working on it The same way
that it's gonna learn what Mint bird is.
Where are the stats? Where are the ad stats?
How do I create a page? How do I create a pop?
How do I come up with my headline? How do I do tags?
What have I checked if I'm missing? Da da.
The same way that we're gonna train guys,
we're documenting everything so that I can turn around
to you when I say, okay, look,
here's the environment you're gonna set up.
Here's the VPS that you're gonna set up.
That's what we did, right?
Because I don't want you to have to go set up a dedicated
system, right?
And then here you can use 5.2 with chat GBT
or you can use Opus, right?
You can use one of those. We'll cover all this stuff
and then we're gonna teach you exactly how to train it.
We're gonna teach you how to set up memory banks,
file centers, like it's gonna be unbelievable.
And then I'm just gonna have a Google Doc
that you're gonna be able to give to your bot
that will learn our whole entire suite,
including the newsletter on a scale of one outta 10.
Does everybody get this right now?
So we're gonna figure out exactly how
to train that bot for you.
And then we're just documenting the whole entire step so
that you can give that bot our newsletter.
And guess what? I don't think it's gonna be able
to use a lot of the software out there.
I think it's gonna be freaking, freaking confused
with what it's supposed to do.
'cause a lot of the software is spaghetti.
It's confusing, not ours.
Ours we made stupid simple to
where I believe we can train a bot to do this.
Does everybody get this? Now?
Is there, is everybody getting this?
So what's gonna happen guys, is I need you to kind
of start changing your ways.
I'll work with you. Like I, I will absolutely,
especially the mastermind man, I'm going to work
with you guys so
that you are now finally implementing AI
and that employee that you didn't know how
to hire that employee.
You weren't sure what the hiring process needed to be,
you weren't sure how to train 'em or whatever else.
That employee, when it learns the business is gonna
keep you on track.
It's gonna remind you of things, it's gonna give you ideas,
it's gonna tell you, Hey, we gotta get the newsletter out.
It's really, really important. It's gonna tell you
how many subscribers you got coming in.
It's gonna tell you when you need to fix your eyes.
It's gonna do all that. And guys,
it's only at the ground stage.
We're at the infant stages of this. Does that make sense?
So now I'm interested. So you guys might remember me telling
you this when AI first came out, I was aware of it,
we were using it, but I wasn't real excited.
When did I get excited? I told you this.
I got excited when the APIs came out,
when we could tie it all into our software.
Then I got super excited and I jumped the board.
And then what happened? All this vibe coding
and all this crap came out.
And I'm like, yeah, no, it's not stable.
And everybody got all excited with all this stuff.
And then the first time those people tried
to go do worse shots for vibe coding, it all blew up, right?
It wasn't where we needed. So I'm like, yeah, no,
I'm glad we didn't jump aboard
that bandwagon, but guess what?
Now I'm ready to jump aboard again. Now it makes sense.
Now it makes sense for me. Now it makes sense for you guys.
And I will take very,
very complicated processes that everybody else has.
'cause they're not teachers, they're not instructors,
they're not coaches, they're not passers.
And I will break it down in very,
very small bite-sized chunks
and you're gonna be able to use it inside of our ecosystem.
Does that make sense to you guys? Time to chat.
Lemme know if you get this, you
get a new lead in your pipeline.
Heck yeah. It's gonna say, Hey, we just had somebody hit our
pipeline, man, it could sit, it can give you a port
of everything that you did all day long.
It can give you a port of everything.
It did everything that all the staff members did.
Every little problem. Like it's
it you, you guys will get it.
Trust me, you will get it.
And you're really going
to appreciate the software suite that we created.
That's, that's all I'm gonna say to you.
Especially the newsletter. Especially the newsletter.
Make sense? So for a lot of you, I told you guys, 2026, big,
big year 2026 is where a lot of us get freed up.
And I told my team this morning, I said,
guys, look man, things changing.
Things are changing really, really fast.
And a lot of people are gonna be let go.
They're gonna let a lot of VAs go.
They're gonna let a lot of graphic artists go.
They're gonna lot, lot, a lot of developers go,
they're gonna let, I don't wanna let anybody go.
I don't wanna let anybody go. I wanna keep you all.
And in order to do that, I want these bots doing everything
that you guys do on a day-to-day basis.
And I want you to be the brains that is guiding the ship,
but let them do all the work.
G pne, let those freaking bots do all the work.
Let the bots send out the emails,
let the bots set up the pages.
Let the bots do the, let the bots do everything.
You help me stay focused with the members,
with the curriculum,
with helping them get to the finish line.
And we need to be cutting edge
and we need to be the first ones out there with everything.
That's my goal. Knowing
that we spent this past year biting the bullet
and building out ecosystems
that people could plug in, right?
And Brian Anderson was the last one.
We could plug things in so that you had income coming in
and in the meantime, now you're gonna be able
to put this bot in there
and it's gonna be able to excel the things you're doing.
Cross the t's, dot the i's, right?
Do all the work for you, check back up with you guys.
That's the future. It's here. It's here.
And you guys are absolutely in the right place. Make sense?
Is everybody clear on this now?
Do y'all understand the goal and where we're going?
And it's already happening, man,
I already met with my team this morning.
We already looked at the updates
and I'm like, dude, this stuff is Jetsons.
It's absolutely incredible, right?
So what I want you guys to do though, alright,
this is what I want you to do.
I'm not excited about AI 'cause I want to teach ai.
I'm excited about AI
because now you have the chance
to be a massive media company.
Does that make sense? How many of you're starting
to connect the dots right now?
You're like, wait a minute. So I don't have
to find the articles, I don't have to write the articles,
I don't have to look and make sure it's SEO optimized.
I don't have to make sure that my site maps
can, I don't have to do that stuff.
It's gonna do all that for me. Yes,
it's gonna do all that for you.
And I'm sure that we can get to the point
where the damn thing's gonna go into your competitor pages
and it's gonna start posting
and it can go into the Nextdoor app
and it can respond to everything
that Jim's teaching you about.
And it can go line up interviews for you,
just like Joshua was teaching.
You guys understand this.
You have the chance to build out an amazing media company.
So now I know a hundred percent without a doubt.
Because it's not just dependent on you
doing all these things.
All you have to do is exactly like I just said, be aware of
what you want it to do.
And by the way, guys, it's going to excel
way past my thought process.
I just turned 50 years old. I forget things, right?
I, I make notes and I'm like,
where the heck did I put my notes?
I'm gonna be like, Hey, you know what?
I got an idea for this app and we need to do this.
Do me a favor, put that in your memory bank.
Let's start that next week.
Next week, rolls around and says, Hey,
do you wanna get started on that app you were talking about?
'cause I mapped out some ideas for you. What do you think?
Yeah, that's where it's at guys. That is where it's at.
So now look at what Tony's saying.
I wish I had Cha's vision and ideas.
You don't need to have Cha's vision anymore.
That's what I'm trying to tell you.
Heck, I don't have to have my own vision anymore.
All I have to do is get this thing
to understand enough about me and my business and my goals
and the tools and the resources
and the day-to-day processes that we either have
or wish we could have and this single learn from you.
And it'll start billing all that out.
Does that make sense guys?
So you don't have to have a vision anymore,
just you gotta get AI where it understands the little bit
that you have and let it figure all that out for you.
Does that make sense? Is everybody starting to see this?
So not only do you have my vision and,
and me opening the doors for all that with the technology
that we buckled down in 2025
and built out seven days a week, right?
We're still not done. I'll talk about that here in a minute.
Um, but on top of that, you know, I have an incredible team.
You know, I have a team of develop.
I'm not letting anybody go. Instead, I brought 'em all in
and I said, okay, I want AI to do a lot
of the stuff that you guys have been doing.
And I want you to be the strategist with me.
I want you to help me set all this up
and solve the the right and, and,
and be the leading cutting edge out there.
Again, like we were at one time, we, we had
to step away to build.
I cannot begin to tell you guys our suite of software
and how important it was
and the fight we went through to have what we have.
I I am so grateful
that we're not stuck on go high level today.
I'm so grateful that we're not stuck on ClickFunnels today.
And no offense to them, it just wasn't my cup of tea.
I tried it. I'm so grateful that we have our own suite
that we can just plug into any ai, any platform,
any strategy without having to go ask somebody
for permission or, and, and, and it's something I can teach.
It's something I, I can put people on a workshop.
I've, I've told you this, I've shown this.
I can put people on a workshop
and they leave with things done.
Do you guys know very much software where you can do that?
Think about it. We built that.
So yeah, I, I took a backseat from the spotlight.
I took a backseat from my wall.
I was like, okay, my wall's dead.
I wonder if I'll even get any birthday, man.
I got like 300 birthday wishes. I'm like, okay.
So people still know I'm there, right?
So now I'm ready to take a front seat again.
As long as I knew that when you came and,
and you were a part of my world, that oh my God,
look at this incredible suite
of software this guy has and I didn't know existed.
I didn't know this Letterman thing.
I didn't know about Bert, I didn't know about gc,
I didn't know about all this stuff.
Where have you been? That's gonna happen.
Does that make sense? Is
everybody starting to connect the dots now?
Oh, you're all starting to get this.
So that was a big exciting announcement that I have
for everybody now I just wanna make sure if I go back.
So now we understand that it is very, very important.
Let me start from the beginning
for those people that are brand new.
And I'm gonna tell you what my vision was in case you missed
it on Friday, because now you understand more than ever,
more than ever, the first thing you wanna do is go
through 1.0, go through 1.0
and learn about why local.
Look at what we built with the newsletter,
choosing the perfect name, the branding,
setting up your first publication,
creating your first newsletter, setting up the signup page.
Learn this stuff, guys. Go through 1.0, okay?
Once you're done with 1.0, then come over here to 2.0
hustle 2.0.
Go through this. You can see people are
already starting to go through this.
And then you're gonna talk about,
we're gonna talk about what's evolved since 1.0.
Okay? And, and we have evolved a lot
and we're still evolving, right?
And how we create newsletters in 2.0
and how you add, you're gonna actually add your API keys.
You're gonna actually create an AI article.
You're gonna actually create a newsletter
by pulling in articles, right?
You're gonna learn about the magic links,
you're gonna add your welcome email,
you're gonna submit your site map to Google,
you're gonna join the inbox syndicate group.
You're gonna set up your auto send is all
that's making sense to everybody.
And then I want you on this call each and every week. Why?
Well, because we're doing something fantastic on this call.
And what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna use this call
to get everybody in the inbox.
Chad, how the heck are you gonna do that?
Well, here's what I want you guys to do.
I want you to do this right now. Let me log in here.
I want everybody to log into Letterman.
Can you guys tell me when you have logged
into Letterman please?
And if you're brand new, just stick with me.
Uh, if you go to that birthday site, Chad
and i.com/birthday, you're gonna have Letterman right now,
but you won't have all this stuff set, set up.
But I'm gonna show you what I want you to do, okay?
So go ahead and tell me when you've logged into Letterman
and I want you to click on publication directory.
Let me know once you've done that. Publication directory.
Publication directory, yeah.
Make sure that everything is purple, purple, purple, purple.
So there's 412 here and I'm gonna subscribe to 129.
Also make sure that you have an email address over here
that you're only using for newsletters.
So I went and actually created a Gmail account called
Letterman newsletters@gmail.com.
You're not seeing my screen. Hold on a second.
Said I was sharing. Let's try this again. Share screen one.
Here you go. Can you see it now? Can you guys see it now?
Good. Okay, so make sure everything is purple.
See there's 412 at the time.
I'm shooting this video and I'm subscribed to 129 and I went
and created this email address right here.
Does everybody have an email address over here that is very,
very unique just for newsletters?
Type in the chat. Let me know.
You want to have an email address
that is only for the newsletters?
Yes.
Arnold says yes.
Dawn says yes. Anybody else? Yes, yes, yes.
Go get an email address
that you're only gonna use for newsletters.
Go get a free Gmail and plug that in there.
Once you plug that in there,
whenever you click on these little envelopes.
And I didn't automate this
process 'cause I'm not gonna do that.
I want you to go and actually look at this
and say, okay, the local Pet insider from
Petersburg, uh, let's see.
Find your flow. Uh, weekly Wave Newsletter. Okay?
This is a niche newsletter, so I'm not interested in
that one right now, but the 4 0 4 Town
out of Atlanta, Georgia.
Yeah. Modesto Metro Buzz. Oh wow.
Modesto La Grange, lowdown. Cool. Uh, save the Kitten.
All right, so this is a local niche newsletter.
I want that one. Long Beach Local Bites, guys,
this is what I want you to do.
Does everybody know how to do this?
Now, the Roswell Roundup, the Chandler Local,
uh, I don't know what that one is.
Uh, roots Weekly, long Beach Business Weekly.
And you can see that you wanna spend a little bit
of time on your publication description, right?
So if your publication is short like Roots Weekly
or Long Beach Weekly, then go back
and update your description.
Okay? Is it okay if we're using our domain as a SubD domain?
I guess so. I don't know. Just make sure
that you can only just make sure that the email address,
that the emails that you get here are only newsletters.
That's all. I don't care if it's a sub-domain,
but just make sure that the email you get here is only
newsletters and that you can respond to that email.
Make sense?
No, that doesn't matter, Michael,
because they can't put theirs in here
until they're sending out.
So no, it only helps you actually, okay,
does everybody get this now?
So the Ellington Weekly, the Parkway Tales.
So how do you appear in this directory when your newsletter
is published and you are actually sending out?
Okay, that's when you appear in this directory. Okay?
Now here's the next thing I want you to do, okay?
If you come over here to subscribers,
choose your publication.
So look, the publication
that I chose is West Valley Shouts, okay?
And that means that I am subscribing
as West Valley Shoutouts.
Okay? So now look, if I come over here to subscribers
and I look at West Valley Shoutouts, I can see
my subscribers versus my peers.
Okay? So for subscribers,
I have 4,000 224, 90 8% of 'em are subscribers.
For peers, I have 1.81%.
So now what needs to happen is when I open this up,
when you guys open this up, you want to see all green.
Does that make sense to everybody?
We're gonna do this every single week
until this turns all green.
So I want you guys to go open up your subscribers right now
and tell me what you see.
What colors are you seeing? Black, red, or green?
And you should probably be seeing all,
but what we're going to do is all,
every single Monday, we're gonna open this up
and we're gonna get to the point where everybody has green.
Does that make sense? Type the chat.
Let me know if that makes sense.
I want everybody to have green. Now what does that mean?
What that means is
that everybody is supporting everybody else.
Okay? That's what that means. Now here's the thing, right?
If you look at what Charlotte's saying,
what if no peer signs up for your newsletters?
There are so many now easily gets overlooked, you can tell,
you can tell who's opening up your newsletter, right?
Versus somebody that is not.
So once we do this a couple times and we go through, okay,
and we give everybody a shot
and we do everything we can to turn everything green,
you're still gonna be left with red
and you still might be left with black.
Black means dead, red means inactive or passive. Okay?
Well here's the thing guys.
There's no doubt in my mind that I can reach out
to Cedar City Insider
and I can say, uh, Hey John,
I saw you on the call the other day, uh,
and I know that I've been opening up your e your newsletter.
Can you do me a favor and make sure you open mine too?
And guess what happens, guys? This turns green.
Does everybody got it?
So is it going to require a little bit
of hands-on once we get going?
Yeah, it's going to. Of course it is. Of course it is.
But let's try to weed out as much of it as we possibly can.
Okay? So now let me just start with this.
Does everybody now know how to get to your subscribers?
Does everybody know how to get to your subscribers?
Hit the subscriber link up here at the top
where it says subscribers.
Yes. Right? When you log in, it says subscribers.
And now you can see you have your regular subscribers,
people that are actually really
subscribing versus your peers.
Your peers are people that went into the publication
directory and clicked on a little purple envelope
on a scale of one outta 10.
How many of you're getting this?
10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10. Okay.
Now what I want you to do,
and we're gonna play a little game here, how many
of you are subscribed to West Valley Shoutouts?
Who is subscribed to West Valley? Shoutouts? Okay.
Joshua's, what's the name of your newsletter again? Joshua.
See, the reason why these are blank is
because over here in this area,
people haven't set their publication.
So we don't know who you are, right?
We don't know who you are.
But let's see if we can find Lake area, uh, uh,
lake Area Buzz over here, which I should have known.
I've been working with Josh lately,
but I just memory is not the greatest
lake area buzz.
All right, let's see if we can find it.
Um, lake area Buzz
Clarkville, scoop
Lake, area Buzz.
Uh, Josh, type in your email address for me.
Rochester Life and Times I wanna find some.
Okay, I think I just saw that Rochester Life
and Times, wasn't it?
Here I wanna find somebody.
Uh, round Rock shoutouts. Glenda, is that Glenda?
Round Rock is Glenda.
Glenda, are you here? This is you, isn't it?
UEA? What the heck does that mean? Oh yes.
Okay, so Glenda, look, you are a dead contact,
which means you have not opened up our newsletter in two
months and 23 days.
Uh, Glenda, would you do me a favor
and go find that newsletter
and open it up for me so we can demo this?
You guys will get this here in a minute,
but look, if she goes
and opens up that newsletter, this is going to turn green.
So what I want you guys to do while Glenna's doing this,
is I want you, and we're gonna do this every single week,
uh, and we're gonna do it very, very fast.
I'm not gonna explain this every single time.
I want you guys to go open up your email, go log into
that email address and go open
and click on every single link in that, in
that in your newsletter.
Can you do that? And then go over to your spam box
and mark all those newsletters as not spam.
Does that make sense? And I'm gonna see if I can open this
up so I can show you guys.
Let me see if I can, uh, do this over here.
Maybe see if I can get in that Gmail account.
And don't worry about it. If
you're confused, you'll catch on.
This is a very, very valuable
thing that I'm doing for you guys.
Okay? So right now, okay, here we go.
Right now I am logged into, um,
I I am logged into my Letterman newsletters@gmail.com.
Alright? And so in my primary, okay, I got Village Buzz,
I opened it up and I'm gonna click wherever I can.
Okay? And guess what? That just helped him out tremendously.
I'm gonna go to Calgary Buzz code too.
And by the way guys, all these are in the inbox.
I'm gonna go ahead and click boom.
Now Google just saw that I opened and I clicked.
I'm gonna go to AZ Florence News.
I'm gonna go ahead and open this up. Boom.
There it is right there. Let me find a link. There we go.
I'm gonna click, I'm gonna get off there.
Boom, let's come back over here.
Let's go to this guy right here. Boca Lux Ledger.
I'm gonna scroll through here.
I'm gonna click we're somewhere. Those aren't links.
Where's a link? Give me a link.
Monday Motivation, gimme a link. Where's a link?
I don't, okay, there we go.
We'll go ahead and read this article. Boom. There we go.
Let's come back over here. Are you guys doing this?
We'll come over here and guess what,
if we do this every single week, it's gonna go really,
really fast, okay?
It's gonna go really, really fast.
And you'll get to the point where you'll recognize the ones.
Yeah. And once you recognize them, you don't have to,
but when you see something new, you're gonna wanna click it.
We can at least come over here, okay?
At least on this call, we can go like this.
If everybody opens just like this, then guess what?
All of these newsletters just got brownie points
because we're doing this as a collective whole.
Is everybody starting to get this right now? Time to chat.
Let me know if you get this. So guess what, if all
of these people were to go log in
and they were to go to their peer dashboard
and they were to sort by subscribers, subscribers, peers.
And if they were to go look at West Valley shoutouts,
I am now in the green for Village Buzz Calgary Buzz, go
to az, Florence, Boca Lake, Nona, Palm Coast Insider,
broad Week Beak, Palm Bay, bay Breeze,
New Jersey Shore Life.
Do you guys understand this? And the only thing
that I have here, the only thing that I have
is our newsletters.
That's it. There's Craig Banks, that's it.
All I got in this account is newsletters. Okay?
So the the bare minimum that I want you guys to do,
and by the way, do you have to wait?
Do you have to wait for Monday to do this?
No, you could do this every single day.
You might learn something, you might soon,
you might see some ideas, you might have some motivation.
Uh, but I want you guys to go into your inbox
and I want you to make sure that you click on each
and every one of these things
because you are helping your fellow teammates.
Is this making sense to you guys? Time the chat.
Let me know if you get this. And I'm gonna remind you,
every single week we're gonna take five minutes every single
Monday and we're going to do this
because I wanna get everybody in the green.
Ron says, you're new moving too fast.
I need a step by step guide.
No, no, no Ron, all you're gonna do is log into
that email account and open the newsletters.
That's it. There's no guide the email account that you use
to subscribe to those newsletters.
Open it up, just open up the newsletters. That's it there.
There's nothing to it. Guys.
I did move fast 'cause I want you guys to move fast.
I want you guys to move fast.
Now, on a scale of one outta 10, does everybody get this?
Just open it up on your phone.
Just always be logged in on the phone
and when you see a newsletter, click it.
That's it. Click it, open it up.
If you can click a link, that's even better.
If you can reply, if I can come down here to Craig Eubanks
and say, oh man, great newsletter Craig.
Google's watching that. Google is watching that.
It is watching for replies, it's watching for opens,
it's watching for clicks.
Now there's a theory that says they're also watching to see
how many people are just leaving
that newsletter unread, right?
So guys, this is how we beat the game.
This is how we beat the game. Do you guys understand this?
And by you guys just doing it on your own time,
we're gonna use the Monday call to clean up.
But by you guys just doing this on your own time,
you will always go to the inbox.
And if you don't believe me,
how do you think all these newsletters are
going to the inbox guys?
So now here's the other thing I want you to do.
That was primary. Now let's come over here to promotions.
And we need to go ahead and open up
and click on the promotions if we can.
And like I said, do this on your own time.
It's gonna make a big difference.
So what happens is we're gonna get the inside pass out
of promotions, right?
And I thought there was a way,
maybe somebody can correct me,
but I thought there was a way to move it to the inbox,
but I don't see it here, right?
I don't, I don't see a way to do it from here.
So right now I'm just gonna recommend that you guys open 'em
and click 'em and that's gonna help get everybody
to the inbox, okay?
And I can promise you by everybody doing this,
it's gonna make a huge difference, right?
So Edmonton Buzz, we're gonna get you
to the inbox, all right?
And, and if we do this, the only people
that you'll ever see hitting spam guys
are brand new newsletters.
Does that make sense to you?
The only people that are ever gonna go
to spam will be brand new newsletters.
Okay? And they'll catch up really, really quick, right?
So we'll come over here, let's go ahead
and open this up, right?
So let me get everybody outta the promotions box. Okay?
So now I'm catching up.
I waited for today to be able to show this to you
'cause I knew that you guys had a ton of newsletters,
but if I do this, you know, a few times every week,
heck man, I could probably have my bot go
and check my email for me in this one account.
Damn, I could probably have my bot open it, click it
and reply to you.
Holy smokes. How cool is that?
See, that's why we do these calls. We gotta write that down.
G did you hear what I just said?
Yeah, We want the bot to open to click
and reply, right?
We can even have the bot probably reply
to the replies, right?
Alright, so we're gonna go through here, right?
So let's just make sure that we got, look,
I already opened all these ones last week,
but I'm gonna go through, I'm gonna open 'em all just
to set the lead, set the example, okay,
here's the Selena Lowdown.
Here's the four 13 Insider. Here's the bridge beat.
Yeah, here's the Monday Edmonton Buzz again. Let's see.
Ed Munchy. I don't know what that one is.
Ed Munchy, the delicious news. I like that logo. Good job.
Uh, good, good, good, good. Rochester Life.
Uh, the South Sound life. There's Mark Jovin.
Yeah, the Acala Sizzle.
Uh, let's see
the Space Coast spotlight, right?
So we're gonna go through and open all of 'em. Okay?
So we open up all the primary, we open up the promotions.
Now we come over here to more
and we're gonna click on spam.
Now here's the people that need help.
Make sense, Charlotte?
To be honest with you, I don't know.
I'm told that they are watching human behavior, okay?
So I don't know. So if I click here,
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna report this as not spam.
I'm gonna report this as not spam.
Uh, this guy here, I don't know,
but I'm gonna report this as not spam.
Uh, Ray Lane needs my help.
I'm gonna report that as not spam.
And the Newport Newser, not spam. Okay?
Can you guys do that for me?
Can you guys do this for me?
If you do these things, you're going to the inbox.
You will always go to the inbox.
So time the chat. Let me know once you've done this.
And now what I encourage you to do is I encourage you
to come back over to your subscribers
and we'll do this for a couple weeks
to get everybody on track, right?
I've shot some videos, it's in 2.0, right?
Everything that I'm covering you guys right now is in 2.0.
Uh, but we'll come over here
and let me open up the right one.
West Valley Shoutouts.
And now I can see once it loads that if I click on my peers,
okay, I'm at 1.8599999999999999%.
But look, I can tell by looking up here
that 20% are opening, 11%
are clicking, right?
13% is inactive, 11% is passive,
and almost 50% of 'em are dead.
Okay? So my goal,
and you can see it's already starting to change.
Uh, my goal is to get everything in the green.
And so before, I mean,
you could start messaging people if you want
to, but I wouldn't.
I'd wait a couple weeks. Let me do my magic with my course.
Uh, see here, there, there's Glenna.
Does everybody see how Glenna just went active?
And why did she go active?
Because she went and opened up West Valley Shoutouts.
So what I'm trying to tell you guys is in a couple weeks,
if you know that you are opening up a Newcomer Digest,
then we reach out to that person
and say, Hey, can you do me a favor
and make sure you open my newsletter, I'm opening yours.
And just like I did with Glenna, then it's gonna turn green.
Now why hasn't this happened before?
Because Chad did a really crappy job at this.
He did a really crappy job.
He just said, here's what you should do. And he let it go.
We're not gonna do that anymore.
We're gonna do this every single Monday.
We're gonna spend about five minutes,
make sure we get everybody to the green.
Is that cool? How many
of you're excited to hear that right now?
This is going to guarantee that you get to the inbox.
This is gonna guarantee you get to the inbox, okay?
Very, very powerful syndicate system that we have here.
Your numbers will start going up.
When you go check your peers, you're gonna see
that they're all gonna go to Green, okay?
They're all gonna go to green.
So you can see, uh, two days thirteens four days.
So four days ago, this person opened.
This person went in active a month ago, 15 days,
two months ago, 20 days, they went dead.
I can get 'em back. So look, Sparta Spotlight,
spotlight just opened eight minutes ago, right?
So he opened on this call, uh,
port Charlotte Matters opened two minutes 18 seconds ago.
That was Jim, right?
Glenna opened eight minutes 51 seconds ago.
Now, can you guys do me a favor?
Seven minutes, nine seconds ago, right? Lane Evans, okay?
And, and make sure you tell us
what your domain is here too, guys.
You wanna make sure you tell us what your domain is
so we know who to go back and reward.
Does that make sense?
Is that make sense?
So look, go back up to go back up
to your publication directory.
Make sure you tell us who we should pay back.
Yeah. L make sure that this says Electric City Shoutouts.
Does that make sense to you? Is everybody getting this?
If you don't tell us who you are,
I just happen to recognize the email.
But if you don't tell us who you are, we don't know who
to return the favor to.
Makes sense? On a scale of one outta 10,
how many of you're getting this now?
10. Josh is 10. Tony's 10 James is 10.
Guys, you'll get this and this'll be so easy
to work with, okay?
You'll get it. It'll be so easy to work with. All right.
So look, I come back over here to my subscribers.
Now, does everybody understand
that you're gonna spend some time in your
subscriber screen, aren't you?
And you know what's gonna be cool is your bot's gonna tell
you every day, like I said, I'm gonna do everything I can
to train you guys to train your bots on Letterman.
It's gonna come back and tell you, Hey man,
you brought in 20 subscribers today.
You kick butt over there in the, uh, freaking,
um, nextdoor app.
You brought in three peers. You see what I'm saying?
Like, it's gonna give you a report.
It's gonna give you a report. Okay?
So now look, uh, one minute ago, pulse
of essay just clicked.
If you go back to your subscribers
and you click on your peers, how many
of you are now seeing recent activity?
And we're starting to see these get filled in.
So like whoever this is 7, 4, 4, 6, 0.
You were active 10 days ago.
Tell me who you are so I can return the favor, right?
Uh, whoever this is Le Letterman newsletters 53.
Tell us who you are. This is a test. We'll remove that one.
Uh, a newsletter, nine 16, tell us who you are.
Newsletter junction@gmail.com.
Tell us who you are, Tony, TK, G.
Hm, clean CDZ Media. We need to know who you are.
We need to know who you are. Does everybody get this?
So, so I'm gonna go through, um,
yeah, we'll fi we'll find a way to automate this
and get these all filled in.
Um, but it's okay.
We'll put this together piece by piece Every single month.
Uh, we will take care of this.
Now the question is how do we put in the peer publication
when your local newsletter is sending
it automatically appears over here.
Just because you create a newsletter
doesn't mean it appears.
We wanna make sure that you're actually sending it.
What the near future's gonna hold is we're gonna tell people
we're gonna score your newsletter.
And so obviously the highest scores will be at the top
and they're gonna get the most subscribers.
Now, why do you want peer subscribers?
Because your peer subscribers are gonna ensure that you go
to the inbox so that when you come back over here
to your regular subscribers, you are gonna get higher opens,
higher clicks, higher everything.
And the reason why is because you're going to the inbox.
Does that make sense?
Does everybody get this? So I'm gonna reward you.
I'm going to reward the people that are doing a good job.
I'm gonna reward the people
that are sending out their newsletter in a timely fashion
that are growing their newsletter.
And I'm going to reward you by putting you at the top so
that when your peers come in here to subscribe,
this will be the number one spot.
The number two spot, the number three spot,
the number four spot, the number five spot.
Everything will be ranked on
how people are taking care of their newsletter.
And those are the people.
Every single time I open up the call, those are the people
that are gonna get every single opt-in.
And that's the reason why I didn't
just automate this whole thing.
That's the reason why, okay?
I wanna make sure that I'm in a position to reward
the people that are doing a good job.
So if you go and send out your newsletter
and you appear over here,
and then we don't see you send out your newsletter
for another three months, we're probably gonna drop you off.
And then when you send your newsletter again,
we'll put you back in.
You'll be at the bottom, but you'll be back in
and then you're gonna have to work your way up.
All right? Does everybody get this?
How many of you are a little bit competitive?
Anybody who's a little bit competitive?
Pretty cool, isn't it?
At the same time, guys, at the same time,
you're gonna go to the inbox, okay?
At the same time you are going to go to the inbox.
All right? So let me take a look at the
new newsletters this week.
Uh, I know G had some, we are are super,
super busy preparing for the birthday gift I gave you guys.
And by the way, uh, if you did not get it, you can go to
Chad nicely.com/birthday.
You're down to a few days, then I'm gonna take it down.
But right now it's still up. Go watch this video.
Go watch this goofy ass video, come over here,
set up your membership, and as soon as you do that,
you are going to get access to 1.0
2.00.
And I didn't show you this. Is there anybody that has gone
and started working in, um,
and by the way, I am showing my screen, right?
Yep. Thanks G. Am I sure? Okay, good.
Has anybody started going through the SMT Quick Start guide?
Anybody at all? Because this is what you guys requested.
It's there. It is there.
So you got 1.0, you got 2.0, you got 3.0, you got the
smaller version of the software.
Why? Because I want everybody sending out
a local newsletter this year.
Everybody. Why?
Because when we go and we start deploying the bots
and they start building your newsletter
and taking care of your registration page
and writing your articles
and everything else, guess what you need to have?
You need to have a newsletter.
So we're just gonna have some fun with that.
We're just gonna build out our media company.
We're gonna build it vertical with the dog, right?
With the, with the cause, with the food.
We're just gonna build all that out
and we're gonna have AI doing all that stuff for us.
But the cool thing is that we have that nobody else does,
is one day somebody's gonna come and write you a check
and gobble you up for millions of dollars.
There's no reason why that can't happen, especially
after what we discovered today.
Would you guys agree? Would you agree?
So now it makes sense. So everybody else could be out there
playing with ai, whatever they're playing and playing
and playing and playing and playing,
but they're not working towards,
they're not working towards a goal, right?
We're gonna be working towards a goal. Make sense?
My course Sprout is wacky. I don't know what that means.
Are you not seeing the course you're looking for?
Uh, let's see.
Unable to. Do people have
to contact support to longing the software?
No. You should already have it.
So if you go search your, uh,
when did you sign up by the way?
Okay, first of all, let me just say this.
The membership I keep showing you on the screen is my
Mastermind membership.
You will not have everything that the Mastermind has,
but you should have the local newsletter Hustle.
You should have Hustle 2.0.
You should have the quick start
and you should have all of these, all
of these replays, okay?
Does that make sense? And I think we've also
got offer Mint in there too.
It should be the Pro, but I'll have 'em look at that.
Can you make sure that's the pro version? Uh, pne. Hi Chad.
I'm new to the newsletters.
Can you highlight the difference between
your software and Beehive?
I can't, I can't.
There's, there's, there's no way.
I can't even, beehive is a newsletter Software.
We're not a newsletter software. We're not.
We're we're a, we're, you're building a media company.
You're putting out articles
that are getting ranked locally, right?
You're using those articles
to automatically create your newsletter.
You're out there running lead ads to bring in subscribers.
You're putting banners
and sponsors like, we're light years beyond Beehive.
And would you guys agree that it's pretty easy?
Would you agree? It's pretty easy?
How many of you would agree
that Letterman's pretty damn easy?
All of our software is easy, right?
So the little experience I have with Beehive about two
and a half years ago, I found it to be very, very technical.
Very, very hands on. That's not us. We're very intuitive.
If you go through 1.0 local newsletter, hustle 1.0,
which we sell from the, from a page right now,
like somebody said they bought it this weekend, okay?
If you go through that, alright, then you'll learn how
to create your branding and why local
and how to create your logo.
Which by the way, all that's changed.
That logo right there was created
with Chad GPT 2.0 in one shot, right?
So all that's changed, okay?
But once you're done with that, go through 2.0, 2.0 is
where we brought in AI 2.0 is where we brought in articles.
Two point, okay? So 2.0 takes you to a whole new level
and you'll wanna send out your newsletters automatically
building up your own reputation.
So I know stuff like Beehive sends it out for you,
but you're building up their reputation here.
You're building up your own reputation on your
own domain, okay?
It's very, very important. There's a big difference here.
So you learn to do all this stuff
and you learn to go out there and do it
for other people, okay?
Jury is still out as I'm going through the course.
Um, okay, where have you been all these years?
How come I found you recently?
I don't know what to tell you my friend.
I, I have been here since 1998.
You've got mail. That's when I first started, right?
A OL instant messenger, right? Yeah.
Plus you're a media company, guys,
you're going to get acquired.
But in the meantime, you get to learn all the new,
I'm gonna bring all the new to you.
I know you want the new, I know you want the shiny,
it didn't make sense before.
Now it makes sense. So I'm gonna bring all the new to you,
but I wanted to make sure
before we brought the new to you,
that you actually had something
that was gonna pay out one day.
'cause everybody else, I'm watching these people
and they're, they're, they're making photos with AI
where they're holding a teddy bear.
Come on. Like, no offense, but how does that pay your bills?
How, how is that gonna have you buy out
for millions of dollars?
Like, how, how is that gonna happen?
It's never gonna happen that way.
Do you guys understand the difference?
Do you understand the difference?
So what have we been focused on?
Not only focused on building a media company,
not only focused on the the newsletter,
but what else have we focused on?
We focused on putting a button on the page.
What else have we focused on?
We focused on email deliverability, getting into the inbox,
making money with email.
All of those things are important.
They're probably, it was probably more important for us
to build that foundation.
We also saw people go build their communities.
We also saw people do their own Zoom calls,
create their own courses, create their own systems, methods,
processes, strategies, secret formulas.
That's where the money comes in.
Now, once you've got that base, guys, it makes sense
to start playing with ai.
How many of you are like, holy crap, now I get it.
How many of you're starting to get this right now?
So, no, I didn't go jump aboard
to shiny objects like everybody else.
I didn't start running events like everybody else.
'cause I knew you couldn't make the money.
I knew they were out there blowing smoke up everybody's ass.
Oh, you're gonna make millions of dollars
for the first time ever.
AI's gonna have you or you're gonna
sell out for a billion dollars.
I heard all that garbage. It ain't true. It ain't true.
'cause you know what? They're not willing to tell you?
Look, this is the first thing they should have said.
There's two people that are at this event right now.
Number one, there's a person that has something to sell
and somebody to sell to.
And number two, there's a person here
that's just living off the AI dreams.
Yeah. How many of, you're starting
to understand this right now.
So now you got people that are playing,
they got their celebrity parents behind them.
So what, you know the person that's making the money from
that, the person that's teaching them how
to put the celebrity parents behind them?
Well, no, no, no. Chad, I was on the call the other day
and it was free.
They taught us how to do that for free. Yeah, sure they did.
'cause they're building their audience.
And then what do you think
they're gonna do with the audience?
They're gonna sell 'em guys. They're gonna sell 'em.
But wait a minute, Chad, you sell us to, of course I do.
I give, give, sell, give, give, sell, give, give, sell.
If I didn't shame on me, why would you listen to me?
Why would you listen to me? If all I ever did was give,
give, give, give, give, give, give,
give, give, give, give, give.
That's not something you wanna learn from.
But when all somebody does is sell, sell, sell, sell,
sell, sell, sell, sell, sell.
Is that somebody you wanna learn from? No.
That's probably something you wanna unsubscribe from.
But guess what? Now everybody's gonna be on a
level playing field.
And I'm telling you right now, I'm gonna come in on probably
80% of your business.
I already met with my team this morning.
I already said document the process that we've been doing.
And now let's just assume
that everybody's sending out a newsletter.
Let's just assume that
everybody's gonna put a button on the page.
Let's just assume that everybody's gonna be using tags
and other integrations.
Let's just assume all those things so that when we train ai,
when we train those Claude models to do all this stuff,
we can simply hand that whole entire package over
to our people, especially our mastermind.
And boom, they're off to the races. So guess what?
I feel like you guys are reborn.
I feel like you get another chance.
I feel like everything that I've been teaching you
that you knew, you knew that there's something there.
Man, there's, if I can just figure out how he's doing that.
Or how the heck did he create that course in a single day?
Or how's he running those ads?
Like you knew, you knew
that we're out there doing these things.
We're not just blowing smoke like a lot of other people.
You know, for a fact, we're doing these things,
but you couldn't connect all the dots.
You couldn't cross all the T's you got, there was a tech.
Well, guess what? Now you got a partner coming into your
business, you got the best CEO coming to your business
that's going to keep you on track.
Does that make sense? I'm excited about that.
I am so excited about that.
And so you're gonna see us like dive head into that.
We're already doing it. We're already doing it.
Everybody's tracking. Yeah, you follow?
I see PNE is jumping in saying, uh,
does anybody have any issues?
Good. All right. Let me show the newsletters to you guys now
that you understand what the birthday gift is.
And there, is there anybody on the call
that has not received the birthday gift?
The birthday gift is the software
where you can create the articles and do the AI
and everything that is selling from our ads
for 2 97 right now.
You got the software, you got the 1.0, you got the 2.0
and you got the SMT of Quickstar for free.
On top of that, there's also, uh, uh, Offerman in there.
And, and there's also, uh,
our affiliate masterclass in there.
I don't know what, where is SW mean?
I don't know what SW means.
All right, let me find the, um, links from G
And by the way, did you guys tell me, is your peers,
are they starting to turn green?
Are the peers starting to turn green? Yes.
Craig says, yes. Deuce says yes.
If you go to your subscribers
and click on your peers, are they turning green?
Are they turning green? Because if you see a name
next to the green, those are people that helped you today,
make sure you help them back.
Okay? That's how we're gonna start the,
make sure you help 'em back the next two weeks.
We'll do everything we can to turn everything
to green on a bulk level.
But if you want, go ahead, start to understand the people
that are clicking on your stuff
and how you can return the favor, okay?
If they don't have their
publication listed, nothing we can do.
We'll do everything we can to get those people in there.
Uh, but for right now, yeah, it's reciprocity.
Make sure you turn s what's that word I'm gonna say?
Rub your back. You rub my back, right?
Um, make sure that you return the favor, okay?
It's important. Alright, let me get the, um,
links from G and we'll announce our new one.
I know today guys, we are building out six different
newsletters today alone.
Six different newsletters, right?
So let me see if I can find it here. Uh, okay, here we go.
So, perfect.
All right, let me see if I can share my screen again.
Share screen. How do I share my screen? Share screen.
Okay, here we go. Okay,
so this is the Irvington pulse.
The Irvington pulse.
All right, I love the logo,
I love these new logos coming in.
They're beautiful. I don't know if
that window's gonna keep popping up.
Let me make sure that window does not pop up real quick.
Hold on a second guys. Let me open up Chrome
because I don't know what the heck that is doing.
Uh, here we go. Irvington Pulse.
Okay, let's see what this looks like. Come on.
Now this is out of, I feel like I know where Irvington's out
of, we should pro,
we should probably start putting the city here on the chat.
Uh, G but now it was opening in Firefox,
but now you do not wanna open in Chrome.
Hold on a second. There we go. Irvington Pulse.
Uh, okay, so here's what's cool.
It's a brand new newsletter,
but look man, they're off to the races.
We created the first two articles.
They've already done all of these articles.
Now what's gonna happen? It's good to see,
but what's gonna happen guys,
is you're gonna see another course come out with me
and Joshua Zamora teaching you how to create these articles
so that you get high rankings in Google as well
as stuff like chat, GPT and Claude.
Okay? So this is great. These are the articles.
Let's look at the latest news. Plain Field's defense.
So this is the I Town is this Irvington, Idaho,
Iowa, uh, rufuss.
Oh, that's good to see you Rufuss.
Um, good, good, good, good Mayors
of Irvington Health Journey inspires community wellness.
Yeah, guys, you're bot is gonna be able
to do all this for you.
Isn't that crazy?
And this is the future of the world, right?
So how many of you recognize that timing is everything,
that the timing could not be better?
Like let's hit this mother like a
let's hit this as hard as we can.
Guys, get your cash out and get out
before the rest of the world is just doing all this
automation on their own, right?
Uh, good. All right, Irvington Bo,
let's look at your subscription page.
There you go. Beautiful job. I love it. Good stuff.
Alright, congratulations Irvington Post.
This is the Torrance Buzz Weekly,
the Torrance Buzz Weekly.
And I can see that, uh,
Chrome is definitely a little bit slower.
There's the logo, the Torrance Buzz Weekly.
Uh, for those of you that just got access today, this is
what you're gonna be setting up.
Okay? Let's go look at the recent newsletter,
see if we can open this guy up.
And yeah, my, uh, Chrome is definitely very, very slow.
This over here. Let me try Firefox real fast guys,
I probably need to restart.
I have not started my computer in a long time
and that's probably what the problem is.
Let's see if we can do it over here.
Okay, so this was a Torrance Buzz Weekly.
Just leave me alone over there. Alright, there we go.
Torrance Buzz. Let's look at the newsletter,
which usually flies open.
Recent articles.
Yeah, is it just my browser g or is everything slow for you?
All right, there we go. A grave
plant thefts on the rise in Torrance.
Plant thefts on the rise. Interesting, interesting.
Arcadia Partners sells Starbucks property in Torrance
for 8.25 million.
Wow. And here's our sponsored posts.
That looks good. If we come over here
to the subscription page.
There you go. The Torrance Buzz. Congratulations.
This is the SV Overlook. This is out of Tennessee.
Here's their articles, Northern Lights illuminate.
Oh, that's gotta be awesome.
Let's look at this article here.
Wow, look at those colors, man, out of Tennessee.
That is crazy. Isn't it crazy to think
that your bot is gonna write this for you guys?
And by the way, what the future holds is you are gonna have
comments at the bottom of these articles.
Isn't it crazy to think
that your bot is gonna respond to those comments?
That is insane to me. Alright, uh, let's see.
The doggone crypto, okay, this is a niche one.
I'm not really interested in niche ones right now,
but we did build this out.
So good. You're off to the races.
Good luck getting subscribers for that.
Super, super expensive. Uh, this is the San Luis Valley.
I was hoping it was San Luis Obispo,
but it's not San Luis Valley.
I think it's outta California.
Uh, let's look at the latest news.
The San Luis Valley beat Outta Monte Vista, Colorado.
Okay, uh, upcoming events, environmental updates. Yep.
All these get indexed.
Good fire noodles Ignites Monte Vista. Yep.
You wanna make sure that you have the city in
the title, right?
That's important. Um, let me look at this one up here.
Upcoming events and environmental updates in Monte Vista.
Yeah. Good, good. Awesome.
Let's look at the subscription page.
Experience the heart of Monte Vista. I love it. Beautiful.
Uh, this here is the Hampton.
Ooh, the Hamptons. I love the Hamptons. The Hampton current.
Spent a lot of time in the Hamptons. Uh, okay.
Hampton Road, Dodges Winter.
Oh yeah, we got the winter storms this week, right?
How many of you are stuck in a winter storm right now?
I talked to Ray Lane this week, he was working on some stuff
and he says, man, I'm stuck in my house.
And everybody's like stuck in the storm.
So here's the thing, man. What an amazing blessing.
You wanna know why. What can you be doing while
you're stuck in the house?
What can you do? What can we be working on?
What can we be working on? Anybody?
How about we get that newsletter out there?
How about we go through 1.0 2.0?
How about we get our newsletter going?
How about we figure out the articles?
How about we go on our way to creating a media company?
Company? How cool would that be?
Yeah, I think that would be pretty awesome, don't you?
Yes. Storm local newsletter. Cool.
All right, let me see.
Uh, Hampton Roads Dodge Winter storm
faces freezing Temps ahead.
Oh man. Up to one inch,
two inch, geez.
3.5 inches.
I was seeing some towns in Russia
where the snow walls were over the cities.
It's insane, right?
So if you're stuck indoors, perfect time
to get your newsletter out there.
Go get you some hot cocoa, light you a fire
and knock out your newsletter guys.
'cause I gifted it to you for my birthday. Right?
Here's the sponsored post, the Venture Kitchen
and bar beautiful Hampton Pirates.
Oh man, this is cool.
I think this is our first Hampton newsletter.
Yeah, Chris says at least 12 inches here.
Oh my God, I do not miss those days at all.
So, alright, so congratulations to those.
Let me just check in with Hannah.
Uh, Hannah, did you have any other newsletters that I needed
to cover today or should we wait till next week?
Let's see. Uh, hold on a second.
Nice. Okay, cool. So look, here's my thing.
Uh, does everybody now have access to the new, uh,
to the 1.0, the 2.0,
the Quick Start guide and the software?
Does everybody have access to that?
Or do you at least know where to set it up?
Type in the chat, let me know.
Yes, yes. I wanna see all yeses.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Go to chat nice.com/birthday.
That's gonna get you access to the membership, okay?
And it's gonna get you access to the software.
Now, here's what everybody told me A day before my birthday.
Everybody promised me
that they would have a newsletter out there
sending for my birthday.
Can you guys do that for me?
That is the greatest gift you can give me.
I turned 50 years old.
All I want is everybody to have their newsletter out there
so that we can start having all this fun with AI
building out your media company.
And you can actually have a retirement plan.
Nobody else can offer that to you.
Nobody can offer that to you.
There ain't a a, a single soul, right?
And let's keep it our secret.
Let everybody else be playing with their little teddy bears
and their celebrity parents
and all that other stuff that
ain't gonna pay the bills, right?
Let's go out there, let's set up our articles.
Let's have our bots set up our articles.
Let's have our bot set up our newsletters,
let's have our bots do all that stuff for us.
Let's have our bots build out the media company.
But you gotta build the infrastructure first.
You gotta understand what the end goal is.
That's what you gotta understand, guys.
And I, I, I know it's crazy
and I know you, you, you don't understand
what we've been experiencing, okay?
You, you think of cha GBT where you have to guide it
or Claude, you have
to guide it Gemini, you have to guide it.
You have to guide it, you have to guide it.
What I'm trying to tell you is everything has changed.
Where it's gonna guide you,
it's gonna learn everything about your business,
it's gonna guide you.
Okay? Um, I'm on course portal.
All I see is Letterman. I don't think so. I don't think so.
Uh, you should go to chat.com/members
and log in there, okay?
And check your email. You should get two emails.
One should say access details, uh, newsletter software.
The other one should say, uh, access details to the,
uh, training course.
Okay? Something like that.
So you got two separate newsletters.
Now look, if you know that you went to the birthday page
and you entered your details,
what you could always do is you could always go
to chat is.com/members
and uh, say, I forgot my uh, password
and it'll mail it to you.
Or you could go to app letterman.ai, which is our software,
and you could say, I forgot my
password, and it'll mail it to you.
Does that make sense? Question.
What if there is no newsletter in the email chat?
I have sort of followed and turned things purple, then went
to the emails where I'm clicking on link in the
inside, those newsletters.
What if there is no newsletter in the email?
I don't know what that means. I, I'm not quite sure.
'cause it would come from the newsletter, right? Johnny?
If you're talking about if you go to your email
and you open up a newsletter
and you're saying there's no newsletter in there,
I don't know what else could be in there
unless Gmail is truncating in.
So yeah, what should happen is,
okay, that's a good question.
When you guys click on the purple envelopes, okay,
when everybody goes and subscribes to everybody right away,
go check your inbox, go check your spam mark.
Everything is not spam.
So as soon as you subscribe,
you should get a welcome email back.
Now look, if you're not getting welcome emails back, it's
because the person hasn't set up a welcome email.
Go through 2.0. And how many of you have a welcome email?
Type in the chat. Let me know who has a welcome email.
Yes, yes, you do that inside a Letterman.
And here's what I'm seeing.
A lot of people have welcome emails, okay?
But what they don't have is they don't have a link
that says click here for the current issue.
You wanna put that in there so
that when somebody gets your welcome
email, they're gonna click.
You want the click Guys, do you understand that?
You want the click, you want real people to click that link?
Did you all just could have think about it
and go through 2.0.
You will see this when you open up the welcome email,
it says, Hey, thank you so much for signing up
for West Valley shoutouts.
Click here to check out our current issue.
And there's a magic link in there.
We have West Valley shoutouts.com/current.
Why? Because we want people to click.
We want them to see our current issue.
Yeah, but we want the click so
that Google can see everybody's clicking on that domain.
Does that make sense? So how many of you just now realize
that you need to go back into your welcome email
and you need to add, click here
to check out our latest issue.
Who's starting to understand this now?
And not only that, once you have that down below, it says,
here's the reason why you wanna check out our newsletter.
We always update with the newest restaurants,
the latest events, the latest happenings, right?
And then what's down below that?
Hey, tell us how long you've lived in Summerland.
What do you love about Summer Alert? Click the reply button.
Or EPL. Why?
Capital R-E-P-L-Y?
Click the reply button
and tell us what do you think we're trying to do guys?
Somebody just showed interest.
We send 'em an email right away.
Click here to see the latest issue.
Make sure you reply to us guys, we're off.
We're off to the races trying
to get you the very best email deliverability possible.
Does it make sense? Now go through 2.0.
Go through 2.0. How many
of you understood more when you went through 2.0?
Like where were you at before?
Like I, I was at like a level two and now I'm a 10.
I was at a three, now I'm a seven. Where were you?
Uh, David, put your hand up. They'll help you.
Yeah, look what Johnny says. Hey there.
Thanks for signing up for Parkway.
Tells your daily Go-to for local life in St.
Joseph, Missouri. Click here to check out the latest issue.
Here's what you can expect each week.
Local news and stories.
Upcoming events and activities, hidden gyms
and favorite spots around St.
Joseph, Missouri. Special shout outs
to local businesses and neighbors.
We'd love to get to know you better.
Just hit reply and let us know
how long have you lived in the St.
Joseph, Missouri area and what local issue
or story do you care most about?
There you go. So they're gonna click to see the latest issue
and they're gonna hit reply
and they're gonna reply to your email.
And now Google says, oh people real people
love this publication.
They love this email.
So let's make sure we send 'em to the inbox.
They pass the test. Make sense?
Pretty cool, right? So let me ask again, what is the range?
Where were you at before 2.0? Where are you at now?
I was a two in my understanding. Now I'm a 10 guys.
Gimme a range. Where are we at? Gimme two numbers.
Gimme two numbers. Where were you at?
'cause I wanna see if that helped you.
I hope it helped you and I'm not done yet. So let's see.
Tech Hall. You were a 10 to a 10.
Charlotte was four to nine.
Who else? It's good.
Nine to 10. Good, where else?
My mastermind members are probably like 10 to 10.
'cause they knew, uh, most of the stuff
that I covered in 2.0 right?
Seven. But where were we at before the seven?
I wanna know where did you start? Where are you at now?
I can see that we're high, right?
So EJ says he was at a one, now he's at a seven.
See that's why it's important to go through
that training, okay?
'cause all the questions that you guys bring up on these
calls and an email
and support, I covered it in a really fun way
inside a 2.0.
Johnny says I start
with a zero now at a 10 with his training.
Good. Frank is one now he's at five.
So how do you get to a 10?
Well guys, you start sending out your newsletter,
you start sending out your newsletter, you'll get to a 10.
And by the way, is there anybody
that has fun with the articles?
Is there anybody that has fun with the newsletter?
Anybody at all? Does anybody have fun with this stuff?
Let's see. Craig has fun. EJ has fun.
Oh, we know Stu Sutherland has fun. Carlos has fun.
EJ has fun. Randy has fun. Sherry has fun. I love it.
Glenna says she does. Johnny says, not yet, but I will.
Arnold says yes. Lane says I love doing my newsletter.
Michael says, yes, I love Atlanta more than Orlando.
Well that's good. So here's the thing, man.
So you're gonna have fun. You're gonna build a base.
I need you to build a base for my birthday,
then I'm gonna come back at you tenfold
and you're gonna learn how to go
and have AI do everything for you.
And I don't say that lightly.
And I've never believed anything more
than what I'm telling you right now.
Okay? So you're gonna have AI do all that stuff for you
and you're on your way to getting gobbled up.
You're on your way to getting gobbled up. I promise you.
There's no way that you're not gonna get gobbled up.
If you follow my lead, you're gonna be too big, right?
You're gonna be too big. You're gonna be all over
Google, all over YouTube.
Like wait and see what your bot's gonna do, right?
You're gonna be too big.
And we're gonna figure that out as a whole.
Yeah, you got a good captain at the wheel, okay?
But you also, I got a, I got an incredible team
around me, around me.
I got an incredible team supporting me.
So my team supports me.
I come to you with everything that we're doing
with our own software
and AI knowing it's gonna do everything for you.
It's exciting time to be alive, right?
It's exciting time to be alive.
And also remember, I gotta meet with Brian Anderson
'cause he's out here in Vegas right now
checking out an Eagles concert.
Uh, also remember we got Brian Anderson.
Is there anybody that has signed off that NDA yet?
Has anybody signed off that NDA to find out
what they're gonna be selling from the phone?
Anybody whatsoever? Because we're building all that in too.
So if you don't think I'm not done with Josh,
I'm just getting started with Josh, I gotta go
and put together the training that Josh did,
add my training in there, right?
Then we're gonna have an incredible training in Core Sprout
on how to rank, how to write the right article.
So there's intention, so there's traffic so
that you get to the top of Google.
We're gonna do all that stuff, okay?
But then we got Brian Anderson
and don't think that I'm not gonna go build out everything
there to support him selling on the phone for you, right?
So I'm just waiting for that NDA. Okay?
So everything's on track, we're completely on track
and now you guys know that we're coming at you full force
with all this incredible AI training
because it's gonna make sense
'cause we have the infrastructure.
Nobody else has an infrastructure.
We have an infrastructure, okay?
Alright Crystal, I'll look into it.
Alright, so let me ask you guys on a scale of one outta 10,
if we get a lot of value on the call
and uh, pne, can you check in with David Road?
He's got his hand up real quick. Let's see. 11, 10, 10, yes.
Ten, eleven, a hundred ten, ten, eleven, a hundred. Good.
Good. So for next week,
please, please, please, please, please.
And I'll try to remind you throughout the week, okay?
Please, until we get your bot doing this,
can you guys open up each other's newsletters?
Can you open it up? Can you click,
can you watch your peer dashboard?
Can you make sure you're subscribed to 'em all?
Can you guys do that for me? Can you do that for me?
So I hope I answer the question.
Chad, why don't you just make it to
where I'm automatically subscribed to all of them
because I wanna reward the
people, I wanna put them at the top.
That's the reason why, that's why I
have not automated the whole thing.
Plus, I want you going through
and reading what your peers are doing
and learning from your peers, okay?
Uh, and I promise you, if you guys will do those things,
dude, there will be no higher quality
with anything you can do.
No higher quality whatsoever.
And you will always go to the inbox.
You will always go to the inbox, okay? Always.
And remember, let me just say this too, guys.
Opens are declining. Clicks are declining.
Replies are not a thing anymore,
which means it doesn't take much
to get you to the inbox.
Do you guys understand that? It doesn't take much.
Okay? There was these services
that popped up three years ago, they're dead.
Google killed them,
but they were automatic bots
that would warm up everybody's inbox, right?
And they saw the footprint. That's not what we're doing.
You guys are real people. Google knows.
Wait a minute, this inbox over here clicked over here,
this newsletter, and we see that they keep doing it.
So there's no footprint.
Like you guys are real people clicking on
and reading newsletters.
It's real. There's no footprint here, okay? So it's legit.
This is how we get in the inbox,
that's the power of the syndicate.
And I'm gonna keep building it up bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger.
That's why I'm re-engaging my whole entire audience
and saying, let me give you a newsletter for your birthday.
For my birthday for everybody's birthday, right?
Whoever's birthdays are in January.
I got two other brother's birthdays are in January, right?
I want everybody to have that. Okay?
If the peer publication column
and Letterman is missing the publication name,
we then email those people.
Yeah, you can. What a great idea.
If you see the emails over there, we've given you the email,
why not email the person
and say, Hey, I just clicked on your newsletter
but I don't know who you are.
Can you or you clicked on my newsletter,
can you tell me who you are?
Sure. Help 'em. Help them. Add their name there guys.
What a great idea. Can you guys do that for me?
Can you guys do that for me? That's a great idea.
Thank you so much for bringing that up.
It never even occurred to me
that we could just send that person an email.
Sure, why not everybody? Why don't you guys do that?
Everybody that you see that is clicking your newsletter
inside your peer section,
if it's blank, send them a thank you.
Say, Hey, thank you so much for reading my newsletter.
I wanna return the favor, but I don't know who you are.
You've gotta go add your publication. Make sense?
Can you guys do that? Because
what you see in your dashboard is different than what I see.
I'm gonna go do it for the people that are reading my stuff
that have for that are reading Connie stuff
that have not gone and uh, put in their name.
But other than that, I don't know what you guys are seeing.
Does that make sense? This was an amazing call chat
and have become a member, but have so much to learn.
So appreciate your generous gifts
and churn through exciting,
happy birthday and thanks for the gifts.
You're welcome. You're welcome. You're welcome.
You're welcome. Alright guys, I gotta go meet with my team.
Thank you. Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
If you're stuck in your house,
please get your newsletter out there.
If you're not stuck in your house, please
get your newsletter out there.
That is the very gift I can have.
That's the very best gift I
can have for the month of January.
50 years old guys, it doesn't feel any different at all.
I still feel pretty young. By the way,
I went bowling this weekend for the first time in like 12
years and it was Strike, strike, strike.
Strike. Four strikes have a score of 145,
so I must not be that old, right?
All right guys, have a good one. Let us know.
We can help our support desk, nice support.com
and I'll talk to you guys again soon.
Alright. Bye everybody.